this is brian de will be reporting from
the ftth council event in munich where
i'm joined by roland montana of I date
Roland you just presented the latest
FTTH figures what are the highlights
well we're just counted the numbers of
subscribers in European au 35 at the end
of 2011 and the result are that in
Europe we are counting today around five
million subscribers it is a growth of
nearly twenty eight percent in one year
so it's quite encouraging but on the
other side if we compare this figure to
what's happening in Russia and Ukraine
for example alone the account also five
million subscribers so it is good good
it is a good result but we have we can
say that the dynamism in eastern part of
Europe is too strong so in a school
report it's kind of good but could do
better how would we how would we do
better yes exactly in fact what we can
say is that it seems that the operators
are more concentrated in the coverage in
terms the growth in terms of subscribers
its twenty eight percent but the growth
in terms of coverage is forty-one
percent so the fact is that when you're
doing the ratio subscribers on home past
is only i would say for you eighteen
percent if you compare this ratio with
the US or Japan for example is nearly
forty percent so there is a job double
job I would say for the operators to do
the third job is to convince the
subscribers to go from adsl2 fiber to
the home and the second the others job
is also to continue the coverage across
the homes in Europe and are you are you
encouraged are you confident that we can
do that what gives you hope that we'll
we'll catch up with other parts of the
world well it's sure that when we
compare Europe to other parts of the
world we are we have a lot of progress
to do because as we are doing also the
panorama for Azure Pacific as your
Pacific alone is counting 15 million
ftth subscriber so a huge gap between of
course Europe
in a pack but nevertheless we have now a
clear objective coming from the European
Commission with the Digital Agenda we
have this clear objective and it is
always encouraging to have such an
ambitious objective this objective is
saying that half of the population has
to be covered with 100 Meg in 2020 so in
some countries we are ahead of this
agenda but in other countries where
challenge are still ahead so do you
think we can do it and if so how can we
do it well a Croatian sign is to say
that at the beginning of fiber
deployment we add those pioneers for
coming from Sudan or Italy and now we
have also dynamics in eastern part of
Europe countries like Hungary like
Slovenia last Rebecca for example but
the equation son is that also in the
main European economies now things are
changing things are starting for example
countries like Spain as a very
encouraging growth attentive subscriber
this year is starting also in the UK and
especially here in Germany also it's
starting as Dutch telecom announce a
special subsidies to finance the ftth
roll out so we are quite in the good
track and i would say especially in the
main economies in Europe to finally
start this ambitious deployment okay
well that sounds exciting news and
thanks for speaking with us my pleasure
thanks a lot ftth connects the world
when are you getting connected ladies
and gentlemen welcome to Munich for the
ninth edition of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future
you